Hey, Drew.
My name is Manasi, and I have been seeing
these beautiful weathered vases everywhere in store.
And unfortunately, they cost hundreds and hundreds
of dollars, which is insane.
So I was wondering if you know how I can make one
of those weathered vases at home
for a fraction of the price.
Thanks, Drew.
(audience applauds)
Here to help with Manasi's design dilemma
is celebrity interior designer and Drew Crew member,
it's Mikel Welch.
Hello.
(audience applauds)
Mikel?
Yes.
Can you just list a few
of the clients that you've worked with?
Michelle Obama, Oprah Winfrey, Tyler Perry, Steve Harvey.
A few.
Right?
(audience applauds)
(Mikel laughs)
(audience cheers)
And if you open a "VERANDA," an "Architectural Digest,"
a "House Beautiful," an "ELLE Decor,"
all of my favorite magazines in the world,
Mikel is right there, front and center.
And it's always an honor to work with someone
who is as esteemed as you are.
Ah, thank you.
Because sometimes
when I do look in those magazines,
I look at the prices of things,
and I get sticker shock.
(Mikel laughs)
I do, too. I do, too.
But luckily, I started off as a set decorator,
so I know the hacks.
Okay, so-
Yeah.
I love when you
give us budget-friendly DIY approaches
because that's something we can all buy into.
Absolutely.
And these weathered vases-
Yeah.
Are like all the rage.
So how do we do this, Mikel?
All right, so let's jump right into it.
So I've started out, everybody knows I love
like craigslist, thrift stores, et cetera.
I started out with a very inexpensive vase.
The next thing that you wanna do is take your paintbrush
and you just wanna give your vase a nice coat
of textured paint.
Now here's the fun thing, Drew.
You don't have to like be a Picasso.
Honestly, you can just go random with it
and just have your way, go all a bit around,
and just keep going.
And what's gonna end up happening
is you've got this kind of like loosely layered light paint
that goes all across the top of this piece here.
So now your vase should start to look like this
as it begins to dry.
Mm-hmm.
So now, you can go ahead and put that one down.
Okay.
I'm gonna show you the next piece.
All right, so now we're gonna get a little dirty.
So this is literally like no money at all.
We're gonna go outside.
We're gonna grab a scoop of dirt,
and literally, mix it with a little bit of water.
Now, bear with me on this one,
but we are going to take clumps of the dirt
and we are going to begin-
Pack it on?
Pack it on, and you want to go right
onto those painted surfaces.
So here. So here's the thing with it.
Don't go super crazy, right?
I don't want you to have like a full layer of this,
like it's all caked up.
(audience laughs)
But just go really...
Girl, what are you over there doing?
(audience laughs)
I, I...
Oh, yeah, we'll get there. We'll get there.
We'll get there.
You know me, Mikel.
I mean, literally, I'm like this with everything.
It's like, I'm a lot,
you know?
(audience and Mikel laughing)
I don't-
Well, I'm gonna be
your design therapist.
I'm gonna help you pull back a little bit.
So I'm gonna say that you can go ahead
and place that down for a second.
Wipe your hands off.
Okay.
So once we allow the piece to dry,
this is what the beauty will look like.
Now keep this in mind, as you're allowing the piece to dry,
what you slowly wanna do
is you begin to remove off some of the dirt.
And you wanna go really slow.
What's gonna happen is over time as it's beginning to dry,
the layers will start to peel off,
and then they will have that smooth patina that you want.
Well, it's kinda like a textured smooth patina.
(audience laughs)
So it's sort of, in a weird way, like sponge paint-
Yes.
But with dirt and earth.
Exactly,
like Joanna Gaines does it-
There's a stipple.
Studio McGee does it.
(Drew gasps)
They all do it, and it's like more expensive,
but don't-
If Joanna Gaines does it,
I am into it.
Exactly, exactly.
(audience applauds)
Look at that.
I mean...
There's no bigger girl crush I have
than miss Joanna Gaines.
And so now you can put your foliage right into the vase
and make a little arrangement.
Ooh, I am feeling this.
And it's super cute.
Super cute.
I think this is so beautiful.
(audience applauds)
I mean, and this, other than my approach, was very easy.
(Mikel and audience laughing)
I love this look. I love it.
Mikel, we'll have these
(audience applauds)
DIY instructions for your own weathered vase
on thedrewbarrymoreshow.com.
(audience cheers)
But get yourself a little greenery and lift your mood.
Thank you, Mikel.
I love this.
Oh, thank you.
(upbeat pop music)